another simple meaty staple that's
perfect for quick easy suppers with a
difference are the Exotic Regional
specialty sausages that have such
distinctive taste and are a million
miles from the Great British Banger here
are four of my favorites that are
definitely worth your money chorizo from
Spain these have an incredibly deep red
color are full of smoky spice paprika
and are great for stuffing stews and
paellas mergys from North Africa made
from beef and mutton these cook super
fast because of the long and thin shape
and can be used in tagines or served
with couscous fennel sausages from Italy
made from pork and packed with sweet
aniseed flavor fennel seeds these are
perfect with pasta or as a topping on a
pizza finally jerk sausages from Jamaica
full of blow your head off Scotch bonnet
chilies these are super spicy and great
in Tangy casseroles or simply sauteed
with onions and garlic be adventurous
with your sausages learn about the
different flavors and you'll soon be
using them to add extra flavor with ease